if you were hoping your progress from
the rainbow 6 siege beta would carry
over once the game came out you're out
of luck Ubisoft has shared new details
about the upcoming Rainbow six siege
open beta writing on the game's website
Ubisoft confirm that all character
progression including inventory and
ranks and not carry forward into the
final game that launches this December
this is not uncommon not only for
Ubisoft games but also titles across the
industry in addition Ubisoft has
confirmed that while the siege open beta
officially starts on November 25th
people who are in the previous closed
beta will get to start playing 24 hours
early beginning on November 24th what's
more the developer stress that the siege
beta content represents just a slice of
what you'll find in the full game
Ubisoft said the open beta will be
focused primarily on testing matchmaking
an online infrastructure and as such
will only feature a limited scope of the
game's content your progression
inventory and ranked gameplay during the
open beta will not carry over into the
final game Rainbow six siege was
originally slated to launch in October
but it was recently delayed until this
December Ubisoft has high hopes for
siege as the publisher said back in May
that the game has the potential to
become the company's best-selling
first-person shooter ever surpassing far
cry 4 at the time Ubisoft CEO Yves giemo
said the games were playability will be
the key to its success it's been a long
time since we last saw the rainbow 6
franchise do you think it'll live up to
Ubisoft expectations and more
importantly we be planning the open beta
later this month